il est 6 heures du matin heure locale
quand l'information est communiqué aux
médias un corps vient d'être découvert à
deux kilomètres à peine du lieu de la
disparition
seule précision il s'agit de celui d'une
femme blanche mais très vite
confirmation est donné c'est bien aura à
coire à 15 ans qui a été retrouvé sans
vie
disparu depuis la nuit du 3 au 4 août
elle était en vacances avec ses parents
dans ce complexe hôtelier situé au coeur
de la forêt malaisienne d'importants
moyens de recherche avaient aussitôt été
mis en place quelques 300 militaires et
d'hélicoptères ou drones et hier encore
ses parents dont son père originaire de
l'yonne lancé un nouvel appel promettant
10000 euros à qui les aiderait à
retrouver leur fille mais en vain donc
reste désormais beaucoup de questions sa
famille comme son grand père refusant
toujours que nora jeune femme fragile
psychologiquement et pu fugué les
autorités malaisiennes ont ouvert une
enquête criminelle pour comprendre ce
qui a pu se passer exactement
aucune piste n'est y ont pour l'heure
été écartée